Hugo Weaving isn't one to be pushed around
even by Mighty Marvel.
The actor recently revealed that he passed
on the opportunity to reprise the role of
Red Skull in Avengers: Infinity War and Avengers:
Endgame when contract negotiations with Marvel
Studios hit a serious snag.
Weaving spoke about the situation during an
interview with TimeOut to promote his appearance
in The Visit, a stage production being mounted
at London's famed National Theatre.
The Skull's reappearance as keeper of the
Soul Stone on the planet Vormir was one of
the more unexpected and crowd-pleasing moments
in Infinity War, but to this day, there are
probably a number of fans who don't realize
that it wasn't Weaving under the makeup.
Rather, it was Ross Marquand of The Walking
Dead fame who so thoroughly nailed Weaving's
take on the character that audiences could
be forgiven for failing to spot the substitution.
"I am prepared."
"We all think that at first.
We are all wrong."
Surprisingly, Weaving indicated to TimeOut
that, in contrast to remarks he made in 2012
indicating that playing the Skull was, quote,
"not something [he] would want to do again,"
he actually enjoyed the chance to indulge
his villainous impulses in the role, and would
have been down to return if only Marvel had
played ball.
The actor explained:
"I loved playing that character Red Skull
it was a lot of fun.
We were all obliged to sign up for three pictures:
I was thinking [Red Skull] probably wouldn't
come back in [another Captain America movie],
but he may well come back as a villain in
[an Avengers film]."
This turned out to be reasonably accurate,
although the Skull was more of a supporting
character than a villain in Infinity War and
Endgame so, what went wrong?
Weaving says that while he was indeed approached
to reprise the role, Marvel basically failed
to abide by the terms of the agreement that
was forged when he signed on for Captain America:
The First Avenger.
Weaving claimed:
"They'd pushed back on the contracts that
we agreed on, and so the money they offered
me [to return] was much less than I got for
the very first one, and this was for two films.
And the promise when we first signed the contracts
was that the money would grow each time.
… I actually found negotiating with them
through my agent impossible.
And I didn't really wanna do it that much.
But I would have done it."
"He resented my genius and tried to deny me
what was rightfully mine…"
Well, that's certainly a bummer to know but,
like we said, Marquand stepped in and absolutely
crushed the role in both movies.
In fact, even though it's tough to envision
a circumstance in which the HYDRA mastermind-turned-Infinity
Stone guardian would make a return to the
MCU, Marquand has enthusiastically stated
that he would love to come back for another
go-round as the Skull.
We have the feeling you're now asking a couple
of questions.
"Wait a minute, Looper," you're asking, "Aren't
they making another Matrix movie?
Will we see Weaving in his signature role
of Agent Smith one more time?"
Yes, they are, and no, we won't.
Hey, you've got questions, and we've got answers,
even if they're not exactly the ones you want.
Later in his TimeOut interview, Weaving explained
that he had indeed been offered the role of
Smith in director Lana Wachowski's upcoming,
as-yet untitled Matrix 4 but unfortunately,
the stars had stubbornly refused to align.
Weaving dished:
"[Matrix 4] is a very different story.
It's unfortunate, but actually I had this
offer [for The Visit] and then the offer came
[for] The Matrix, so I knew it was happening,
but I didn't have dates.
I thought [I] could do both, and it took eight
weeks to work out that the dates would work
— I held off on accepting [his role in The
Visit for that period].
I was in touch with Lana Wachowski, but in
the end she decided that the dates weren't
going to work.
So we'd sorted the dates, and then she sort
of changed her mind.
They're pushing on ahead without me."
That is also a bummer, as it either means
that Matrix 4 will be without Agent Smith
altogether, or will have to fill the role
with someone other than Weaving, whose icy,
near-mechanical delivery helped define the
character.
We can't help but wonder if Wachowski has
given Marquand a call; he does a pretty solid
Hugo Weaving impression.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.